[Music]
welcome back here to another episode on
my channel firm learning welcome to
another coffee break as you can see
today's video is going to be a bit
different it's a sunday here in munich
sitting on my balcony enjoying a nice
brunch with a couple of friends and
indeed today i'm just going to guide you
through the day and the highlight of
today is going to be a meetup the very
first firm learning meetup is happening
in the beer garden here in munich and if
you didn't know about that that's
probably because you don't follow me on
instagram where i do these kinds of
announcements so follow me to stay up to
date for that uh trust is going to be
some great impressions later today that
we are going to see
next to me i have paul with me here
today paul is the co-founder of building
raider one of my colleagues and we
recently had a couple of mba students
visiting us in munich at our office at
building radar and we just had a
discussion with them what's like to
found a business what's like to found a
startup and actually thought that you
made a couple of very great points on
what's that like
some pointers to guide people for their
decision would you mind just sharing
your thoughts on this topic here first
thanks helen before the great breakfast
here it was really nice to sit here in
the sun
and yeah so basically with the students
we were discussing whether it makes
sense to first get some work experience
in a proper company because that
obviously can help you when you deal
with
professionals in your startup life and
on the other hand it's all about i mean
founding a company is all about
risk-taking and we were basically
discussing the pros and cons of starting
a business right out of university or
maybe first giving it one two three
years in for example management
consulting because you can also learn a
lot about different industries
and my opinion which is obviously biased
by my own experience is i would always
try to do it right out of university
because you basically have nothing to
lose like you are used to a very
basic standard of living and
worst case you can still just get a job
after six months if your business fails
and i think that was a pretty
interesting discussion there
[Music]
so we are done with the brunch now our
friends left we just tidied up the
apartment a little bit we had three
little kids here so it was a little bit
messy indeed but now we have the time to
film a couple of tick tocks so recently
tried to step up my tik-tok game a
little bit we'll also insert the social
it's somewhere here check it out nicolas
my videographer is here as well who will
now help me with that so let's get into
it
it is so important to do that right make
sure you follow these crucial slips and
share three key tips that i believe will
really make the difference for them
first you need to have strong academics
so make sure you have good gpas done
lots of internships and this will then
help you significantly to get that done
[Music]
so we just filmed a couple of takes at
home and thought it might be great idea
to also make use of the nice scenery the
nice weather so now we moved here to the
easer just to create a couple of
additional tick tocks so let's do that
right now and then afterwards we'll go
to the firm learning meetup very excited
to meet many of you there as well
how much do you save every month is it
ten percent of your annual income to
build well
it always surprises me our business
students who spend the whole bachelor
[Music]
so we just created a couple of
additional tick tocks here at visa next
to me is actually nicholas who is my
videographer so he is responsible for
some of the firm learning videos that
you've seen over the last months so
thanks nicolas really for all your work
that's much appreciated
and um yeah so let's move back to our
apartment and then let's see what we do
next probably sooner moving to the meet
up very much looking forward to that
[Music]
so we are on our way to the meetup now
just a little pit stop at home very much
looking forward to it so a couple of you
already texted me you can do it some
others told me now they can't do it and
so on so let's see how many of you are
there if you've missed it again these
are things i announced on my instagram
so follow me there to stay up to date
i'm here with my wife and our baby girl
by the way we are expecting now our
second child it will come likely in
november the doctor didn't really know
yet whether i was going to be a baby
girl baby boy like your boy but let's
see very excited to meet all of you
let's see us there and all the rest so
now we're here this is the augustina
keller it's one of the well-known beer
gardens here in munich this is where i
invited you here for the meet up looking
forward to that let's go in and let's
see how many of you are here very very
excited to meet all of you
[Music]
it's headless yeah yeah
but
i think the more
fun approach it was to do whatever you
like
[Music]
yeah so so thanks for all of you joining
it's really a pleasure that all of you
are here
it's really the very first time i'm
doing anything comparable to this to
such a meetup usually maybe i get some
messages from you on instagram on
linkedin or email or whatever and then i
can text with some of you and that's
already a pleasure as well but seeing
all of you here right now today here in
the beer garden that's really really
cool
i hope you're enjoying yourself as well
maybe getting to know some some new
people i talked to many of you already i
think lots of very ambitious
professionals or students
so uh great that i meet all of you
so how did i start from learning because
this is something that also some of you
asked me
now today
it was early 2020
and uh i was just out of consulting
and as you all know it's not a myth
right but in consulting you have rather
long hours so suddenly i didn't have all
this work in the evenings i had a bit
more time and then i was sitting at home
i think my wife just left
but i was talking to my wife okay what
what do i do with all my evenings now
right what do i do with my time of
course then the new position or it was
not like it was a nine to five right but
surely it wasn't like a nine to 12 or
something so lots of time in the evening
and i was already you know starting in
this trap i was now watching netflix
episodes in the evening just relaxing at
home and that's fun of course
but i didn't feel like that was the end
game to do that every day and then i
told my wife what about starting a
youtube channel wouldn't that be a great
idea
and then my wife told me again like
unfortunately she just left but she
would confirm right she would tell me
are you crazy like starting a youtube
channel who's doing that like who's
starting it and obviously she was afraid
that everybody would would make fun of
me and so on right and i think a lot of
people also did make fun of me like in
the first months after i started the
videos i mean as you can imagine right
you know like starting a youtube channel
of course people talk
whatever
the more thankful i am that right now
i think the from learning platform is a
platform that brings together people all
of you are here now it's really
something that makes me super happy
super proud that all of you are here we
are enjoying this time together so thank
you for that
let's all race our glasses i think to a
good afternoon thank you and cheers
great that you're all here
to use
[Music]
[Music]
so hope you enjoyed all these
impressions from the very first firm
learning meetup for meals for sure still
something very special to see how many
people came here to get to know my
audience it's a great pleasure and as
always if you liked it leave a like
subscribe to the channel big big thanks
to all the members for checking this out
i'm going to be back next week next
saturday with the last video all the
best to you my name is heinrich ruizing
weekly content hyun from learning and
bye